- What we're going to do in this video is
talk about factors and factor pairs.
Now when we talk about factors,
these are really numbers that
can be multiplied together
to make some number.
So, for example, if I were
to talk about factors of six,
I could multiply two
times three to get six
and so we would say that two
and three are factors of six.
In fact we would also
say that two and three
is a factor pair for six
'cause when I multiply
those two I can get six.
Now to think about all of
the different factor pairs
for a number we could think
about it in terms of area.
How can we make a rectangle with area six?
Well you could do it if it's
two units by three units.
So it could look something like this,
I'll just hand draw it.
So let's say it has, so
let's say our rectangle
looks like this.
So it has two rows and then three columns
and lets say these all have equal area,
it's hand drawn but you
can see that the area here
would be two times three,
which would be equal to
six square units.
Now, what if, what are other
ways to get to an area of six?
Well you could have
something that is one row
but then it has six columns.
So maybe it looks something like this.
It looks like this.
So it's one row and then
you have one, two, three,
four, five, and I want them all
to be roughly the same size.
So it's one times six would
be also an area of six
so that would be another factor pair.
We know that two times
three is equal to six
and we know that one
times six is equal to six
and these are actually the
two factor pairs for six
and we can do it with larger numbers.
We could think about what
about all the factor pairs
for something like 16?
Pause this video and see if
you can think about that.
Well I'll set up a little
table here to think about that
and so in this column
I'll put the first factor
and in this column I'll
put the second factor
and the way I like to
do it is I start at one
and I keep working up, up to the number,
to try to figure out all of the factors.
So let's start with one.
So one is definitely divisible into 16
and as long as you put
a whole number here it's
going to be divisible by one
and we don't have to multiply
by one to get to 16, we'll
have to multiply it by 16
so that's a factor pair
right there, one and 16.
Now what about two?
Does two go into 16?
Well sure, two times eight is 16 so
that's another factor pair.
Two times eight.
We found another factor pair.
Now what about three?
Does three go evenly into 16?
Well no, three times five is 15
and three times six is 18
so three doesn't go into 16
so three would not be a factor of 16.
What about four?
Well four times four is 16 so
that's a factor pair there.
Four and four.
What about five?
Well no, five times two is
10, five times three is 15,
five times four is 20.
Five does not go evenly into 16.
Same thing for six, six times two is 12,
six times three is 18,
does not go evenly into 16.
What about seven?
Seven does not evenly go into 16.
Seven times two is 14,
seven times three is 21.
What about eight?
Well we already know that
eight goes evenly into 16,
you might be tempted to say
oh there's another factor pair
of eight times two but we
already wrote that down.
We just happened to say
that two is the first factor
and eight is the second
factor but you could
say it the other way around
so we don't have to then
go to eight times two.
And once you've gone half
way you can be confident
that you've already found
all the factor pairs
because then you could go to nine,
nine doesn't go into it,
10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15
but then 16, of course, is divisible by 16
but we've already written
that here in this factor pair.
So we have these three factor pairs,
one and 16, two and
eight and four and four.